[Música]
hola
hoy te quiero compartir el arma secreta
que hace realidad todos tus sueños con
esta herramienta puedes crear
literalmente todo lo que quieras yo hice
uso de esta herramienta y mi vida cambió
180 grados hace exactamente 20 años
estaba en un estado depresivo o sea
sentía ansiedad todo el tiempo sentía
culpa todo el tiempo estaba perdida no
sabía que quería hacer con mi vida y
después de aplicar esta herramienta mi
vida cambió por completo
hoy me reto y me divierto como
empresaria me convertí en facilitadora
del desarrollo humano y he tenido el
privilegio de acompañar a miles de
personas en su proceso de transformación
personal y profesional forme una familia
en fin esta herramienta es tremenda y yo
te la quiero compartir hoy pero para que
no se te olvide te late si hacemos un
experimento
si o no venga entonces chécate para el
experimento vas a tomar la hojita que
tiene esta figura y con tu mano lo que
menos uses vas a detener la hojita con
tu mano que menos uses y con la mano que
más usa vas a detener el péndulo es un
péndulo en el dulce con el hilo lo vas a
sostener a modo de péndulo ok y te voy a
pedir para que funcione porque fíjate no
puedes mover para nada el cuerpo en este
experimento para nada ok entonces la
postura ideal ahí como estás sentada es
que recargas el codo y detengas la hoja
y pongas tu péndulo exactamente arriba
del centro del círculo el péndulo no no
debe de rozar la hoja ok esa es la
postura va a durar muy poquito así que
recuerda no mover tu cuerpo para nada va
tú quédate en esa postura y yo te voy a
guiar
muy bien lo que te voy a pedir entonces
es que te enfoques totalmente en eso
no requieres mover tu cuerpo para nada y
tu pensamiento central ahorita va a ser
péndulo desplázate de asia de péndulo
desplázate de a asia ve y enfócate en
eso
ábrete a la posibilidad de ver qué
ocurre sin que muevas el cuerpo a ver
qué pasa
y algunos de ustedes ya se les está
moviendo si es así pídele que se
desplace a mayor distancia si no se te
mueve aún respira
la siguiente instrucción es
péndulo desplázate de ese ave
y nada y exhala
péndulo desplázate de c a b a los que ya
se les está desplazando el péndulo
pídele que se desplace a mayor distancia
a los que no y nada e insiste péndulo
desplázate deseado
pues cuando cuente tres sueltas el
péndulo y te das solo un aplauso a 123
suéltalo hay un aplauso
[Aplausos]
ok
a ver
[Aplausos]
levanta la mano si tu péndulo se movió
de ave o deseado
eso la mayoría gracias no hicieron
trampa verdad oa eso muy bien a ver
vamos a analizar qué ocurrió vamos a
analizar qué ocurrió fue arbitrario fue
brujería qué pasó
bueno la explicación hay una explicación
y la razón por la que algunos se les
movió el péndulo y a otros no se llama
cp te comparto el cp yo le llamo así
este mecanismo por las iniciales de sus
primeros tres elementos se de creencia p
de pensamiento en emoción este es un
mecanismo que tenemos todos los seres
humanos dentro y que es responsable de
cualquier resultado que creo en mi vida
entonces en este ejercicio todos todos
usaron su mecanismo cp la diferencia fue
que a los que sí se les movió el péndulo
le pusieron un contenido distinto a su
cp ya los que no se les movió el péndulo
para nada generalmente la tendencia es
que a los que sí se les movió el péndulo
el contenido que pusieron en las
creencias fueron como he puesto es
posible al hombre
si se puede mover ay qué loco entonces
eso generó pensamientos como ya estamos
viendo qué divertido no y entonces eso
genera emociones como bienestar como
sorpresa como alegría ok la tendencia de
los que no se les movió el péndulo
generalmente tienen creencias tomás esto
es imposible un péndulo sin que mueva yo
la el brazo no no y generó pensamiento
es como hay estos aburridos qué sentido
tiene esto es una loquera y entonces
generó emociones como pus apatía como no
me gusta etcétera no ok pero qué crees
que tu mamá nada más o sea no usas el cp
es sólo para mover un péndulo con tu
enfoque tú y yo lo estamos usando todo
el tiempo y está creando resultados todo
el tiempo
de hecho el mecanismo completo es
creencia pensamiento emoción luego de
acción y rd resultado que significa esto
que cualquier resultado de tu vida o sea
dinero sobrepeso que me quieran el cual
quiera
parte de una creencia que es una idea
super abstracta es una idea pero esta
creencia se va materializando durante
todo el mecanismo hasta convertirse en
un hecho visible que yo le llamo
resultado entonces una creencia no es
nada más que una idea que yo doy por
hecho que es verdad aunque tenga
evidencia o no de eso entonces esa idea
va a generar pensamientos y pensamientos
y cuando yo ya tengo muchos pensamientos
acerca de esa creencia entonces mi
cuerpo va a generar reacciones
bioquímicas y esas reacciones me van a
dar mucha energía o poca entonces si yo
tengo mucha energía o poca pues realizó
ciertas acciones o no y eso me va a
traer los resultados que yo obtengo en
mi vida ver otra cualidad del cp
es que puede operar de dos maneras o
parte de una creencia empoderado ahora o
sea como yo valgo yo merezco entonces si
tú tienes esa creencia va a generar
pensamientos como orales aunque no
tengan los recursos me voy a aventar yo
voy a salir adelante entonces eso me va
a generar emociones con mucha energía
como pasión como compromiso
determinación y cuando yo tengo mucha
energía entonces ahí si puedo ser
disciplinado y llevar a cabo todas las
acciones que requiero y eso me va a
traer resultados que generalmente son
los que espero y eso refuerza entonces
fíjate si pude fíjate si va algo la otra
forma en la que el cp puede operar es
todo lo contrario que parta de una
creencia el limitante como yo no soy
suficiente yo no me lo merezco yo nunca
voy a poder entonces eso genera
pensamientos en ese orden y las
emociones que me van a generar como
miedo
o apatía son emociones con muy poquita
energía y cuando yo tengo muy poquita
energía pues es muy difícil que me
desperté temprano a correr o que haga
cosas que me van a llevar al resultado
que yo quiero entonces como el resultado
no es bueno se refuerza efectivamente no
soy capaz de a vista
otra característica del cp es que no
para mientras tú y yo estemos vivos el
cpd va a estar generando resultados una
y otra vez lo único que está en mi
control
no lo puedo parar pero si es que
contenido le pongo a mis creencias hacer
uso responsable de mi cps sería decir
para mí si ahorita tengo una crisis
financiera esto no es culpa de méxico o
de alguien más esto parte de una
creencia limitante que yo tengo pero si
yo no hago eso mi jefe va a operar sólo
o sea por inercia y qué significa que
opere por inercia que va a tomar la
creencia que me sea más familiar y no
necesariamente la creencia que me
conviene más entonces por ejemplo
hagan de cuenta una creencia que no me
conviene por ejemplo es que si yo
aprendí en mi casa que mi papá trabajó
40 años en un lugar que aunque no le
gustaba eso hizo si yo no me
responsabilizo de ser mis cpi cambió el
chip generalmente yo voy a acabar
haciendo lo mismo o si yo nací en una
cultura no tuve la suerte de nacer una
cultura con creencias empoderado horas
donde lo que más se repite es no puedes
es si naciste pobre te vas a quedar
pobre no entonces si yo tengo ese
pensamiento lo más probable entonces es
que yo dé por hecho que sí que no puedo
sí mostrando entender ok entonces a este
punto ya te habrás dado cuenta que todo
el chiste para obtener lo que quiero es
aprender a sustituir mis creencias
limitantes por las empodera horas cierto
a ver cómo se hace eso
ahí te va te voy a compartir una
sugerencia de cómo creo que puedes hacer
esto el paso cero es reconocer que yo
soy el único responsable de lo que me
está ocurriendo en la vida y para esto
te voy a compartir una anécdota anécdota
personales pero no le vayan a decir a
nadie secreto
hace siete años yo participe en un
programa de televisión como cantante y
durante 13 domingos cantaba una canción
totalmente en vivo delante de 8 millones
de personas y entonces mucha gente me
decía guau qué padre oportunidad no y yo
fingía no no si no sabes lo estoy
disfrutando pero la neta la neta la neta
yo no me la estaba pasando bien o sea
estaba apanicada todo el tiempo y me
estaba auto saboteando osea un domingo
se me olvidaba la letra de la canción
otro domingo me temblaban las piernas y
no podía salir otro domingo etcétera me
auto saboteaban y además tenía mucho
miedo y no podía superar mi miedo
correcto entonces yo también me acuerdo
que en ese momento yo decía nada de esto
me estaría pasando y cantaría
maravilloso y no tendría miedo si tan
solo la producción me asignará las
canciones que a mí me gusta o si tan
solo fulano del 'stand' fuera más amable
o si tan solo x oye
o sea el punto es que yo estaba
convencida de que yo cantaría increíble
que mi vida sería diferente si alguien
más hiciera lo que yo quería y que creen
la única responsable de que yo estuviera
pan y cada y que me estuviera saboteando
era yo misma porque solo yo y nadie más
decidió estar en un programa cuyas
reglas eran así entonces en este punto
es entender que si yo soy un adulto yo
soy el único responsable me guste o no
de la vida y de los resultados que estoy
teniendo una vez que entiendo este paso
entonces el paso 1 es darme cuenta de mi
negatividad cuando te digo no esto no es
decirme ay soy muy malo ahí esté estoy
estoy en iba a decir soy 16 no no no no
se trata de decirme eso se trata de
reconocer que no estoy perfecto que a lo
mejor de lunes a viernes soy perfecto
pero hay días que no usted es decir es
reconocer que yo tengo creencias
limitantes en ese ejemplo del programa
que les estoy dando mi negatividad
consistía en que yo miren les confieso
en ese lugar porque tenía una necesidad
enorme de que los demás me aplaudieran
de que los demás me reconocieran de que
los demás me dijeran wálmaro porque yo
no podía hacer eso conmigo misma o sea
la creencia limitante que yo tenía era
que si los demás no me demostraban que
me amaban yo no me podía amar y te lo
prometo que yo me sabía este choro
mareador de puedes sólo amar si te amas
a ti mismo eso lo sabía pero la neta la
neta es que yo estaba practicando otra
creencia entonces si tú tienes problemas
de sobrepeso si tú tienes nos estás en
una relación violenta de pareja si tú
tienes una crisis financiera entender
este punto es lo único que está pasando
no es que yo no sirva no es que yo no
sea competente es que simplemente estoy
practicando una creencia limitante que
aprendí en mi infancia o que aprendí en
mi escuela y es momento de dejar atrás
esa creencia ok
el siguiente paso entonces es busca un
espacio en el que pueda ser escuchado
con compasión a qué me refiero con esto
un espacio en el que tú puedas hablar
con tu verdad que sea confidencial que
sea seguro cuáles son estos espacios hoy
el mundo está lleno de coaching de
meditación de sesiones terapéuticas de
yoga de reik y hacer ejercicio con un
grupo de gente hasta en fin hay muchos
espacios y es necesario porque en ese
espacio no nada más voy a poder yo con
honestidad hablar de lo que me ocurre y
darme cuenta sino que además voy a
aprender de otras personas que pasaron
por un proceso similar entonces ábrete
el espacio
el último paso es toma acción diaria de
aquello que te haya funcionado lo que a
ti te haya funcionado si a ti te
funcionó por ejemplo meditar 15 minutos
en la mañana y con eso cambia tu estado
emocional
hazlo si te funcionó no sé más bien
correr y pegarle una pera de box cuando
estés enojado hazlo pero la clave es
hacerlo diario miren la única diferencia
entre la gente más exitosa del planeta y
los que no es que lo que hacen lo hacen
diario estén enfermos sea domingo estén
cansados es diario ok entonces el arma
secreta para lograr todos los resultados
que quieres en tu vida es construir y
mantener creencias empoderado horas
y mira ahí estoy yo la paracaídas
el centro el otro es un facilitador en o
es mi esposo
entonces el sentido de tu vida y de la
mía este es mi punto de vista muy
personal es construir y expresar mi
máximo potencial o sea mi máximo nivel
de salud mi máximo nivel de inteligencia
mi máximo nivel de amor y de emociones
mi máximo nivel de espiritualidad es
expresar al máximo y no negociar lo y lo
único que te puede impedir llegar al
máximo potencial de tu vida a lo que
sueñas es una creencia limitante es algo
abstracto es una idea que te puede
cambiar en un segundo porque está
abstracto entonces estás listo tú puedes
y no negocio estos sueños para nada
gracias por el privilegio de
acompañarnos
[Aplausos]